Janet shamlian is outside the Santa
Clara Valley Medical Center in San Jose
which is treating seven people hurt in
the shooting two of them are related to
the young boy who died in that attack
Janet what do we know about them there
is nothing but heartbreak here this
morning Michelle a six-year-old boy
Steven Romero died in the attack this
morning his parents rather his mother
and his grandmother who were with him at
the festival are being treated here for
gunshot wounds we did speak to Stevens
father and he said probably the only
thing a parent in this situation could
say is that it had been the worst day of
his life he is now here with his other
family members this is considered one of
the leading trauma centers in the area
the hospital tells us that they are
monitoring patients in conditions
ranging from fair to critical condition
several who have had to had surgery and
one was treated and released overnight
also another couple is being treated
here
they were also shot they were selling
honey at the festival the man is on a
ventilator this morning but is expected
to recover among the victims being
treated elsewhere at a Regional Medical
Center in Gilroy and at Stanford are a
12 year old girl Leslie a woman named
Wendy toner and a man Francisco Aguilar